welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man has been
conspicuously
missing from crises that definitely need
him from the arrival of carnage and
venom let there be carnage
to our lives a desperately needed update
on spider-man no way home like our
amateur attention spans need our hero
where's spider-man why wasn't he in
falcon winter soldier why wasn't he in
the snyder cut
the short answer is not every marvel
story is a spider-man story
and there's not always room in the
budget for tom holland and the team of
ninjas to poison everyone he
accidentally spoils the plot to
damn it however since spider-man no way
home may
cross over different universes we may
have a
deeper answer to where spider-man is and
a pretty good idea of what sony could be
cooking up for their joint marvel
studios event coming at the end of the
year
spoiler warning in case i'm right about
if not it's okay because it's more fun
to be surprised so in the venom let
there be carnage trailer other than that
spider-cletus cassidy smacks spider-man
is kind of a no-show in this movie a
decision made by sony and director andy
serkis to set this movie in its own
world
inspired by the world of spider-man with
daily bugle newspapers stan lee cameos
and the ravencrop
institute but not the webslinger himself
we're treating this very much
as it hits his own world the venom story
is his own world there are nods
and little moments that you just like
this newspaper the daily bugle of course
but on
on the whole he's unaware they are
unaware
at this point of other characters like
spider-man that's the way we've chosen
to play this particular
episode of the movie but well we'll wait
and see we'll see what what little
uh things you can pick out of it the
first venom and venom let there be
carnage are not part of the mcu
now back in 2017 sony had amy pascal
confused the [ __ ] out of kevin feige by
saying they might be connected
and that tom holland spider-man meeting
tom hardy venom would be inevitable
you never know when spider-man is going
to end up interacting with venom because
that's inevitable but
while spider-man is not part of venom
and carnage's story
circus's wording left the door open with
the tease that he might
soon be like notice how he said they are
unaware at this
point of other characters like
spider-man and the way we've chosen to
play
this particular episode of the movie but
we'll see and whether or not you think
that's reading too much into it it might
be
it's still weird for let there be
carnage to lean even more into
spider-man's world if the first movie
was successful enough without really
making
any references to spider-man at all i
mean really that 2018 film went out of
its way to avoid mentioning the daily
bugle eddie left new york due to some
vague incident with the daily globe
we don't want a repeat of the daily oh
really baby you were run out of new york
i don't want you run out of san
francisco
by comparison this sequel is going all
in on spider-man references
with multiple daily bugle sightings in
the trailer alone
implying the existence of the daily
bugle editor jay jonah jameson now it's
unclear if we're talking jk simmons
though because he now plays jameson in
the mcu as a different version of the
character and alex jones style
conspiracy theorist but whoever the j
jonah jameson is in the venom universe
remember he's a grieving father because
the opening minutes of venom identified
that astronaut as
jameson one of the astronauts is still
alive that's jameson even named in the
credits as
astronaut j.j jameson iii who in the
marvel comics is the astronaut son
of the daily bugle's editor-in-chief j
jonah jameson and since the riot
symbiote killed him in that movie that
makes the j
jones of this universe in a very dark
place and in this very dark world peter
parker may not be part of it because he
has not yet emerged as spider-man
or at least hasn't left the friendly
neighborhood enough for folks on the
west coast to think about him or going
by the dark tone of that version of j
jonah jameson this could be set
after an alternate reality peter parker
has died which would clear the way for
sony to introduce the live-action miles
morales or gwen stacy but before we
continue thank you to skillshare for
sponsoring this video skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes for curious
creative folks
skillshare lets you explore new skills
deep in existing passions and get
lost in creativity skillshare offers
classes designed for real
life learn and grow with short classes
that fit any schedule
each class is a combination of video
lessons and a class project they have
classes and topics new rockstars fans
will enjoy
like animation film music freelancing
one of their classes that sounds really
fun and delightfully specific
is creative illustration drawing sea
monsters taught by illustrator ira marks
the class not only shows you how to draw
the creatures that live on the edge of
old maps but goes into the theory and
history of them as well
and as someone whose fiance is working
on the pixar film luca i have a sudden
new interest in sea monsters and what
they're like it's curated specifically
for learning
meaning there are no ads and they're
always launching new premium classes so
that you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you
and it's less than ten dollars a month
with an annual subscription the first 1
000 of our subscribers to click on the
link in the description will get 30
off an annual premium membership so that
you can explore your creativity even if
you've already had a free trial of
skillshare you can still take advantage
of this offer to get a full
year of unlimited learning and creative
exploration either way the end game
seems to be sony planning to
merge this venom universe with their
other spider verses because remember the
first movie's second post-credits scene
was a tease for the animated spider-man
into the spider-verse which segued with
meanwhile
in another universe as if this venom
universe that we're leaving
is just one of many universes in a vast
spider-verse
now spider-man no way home will be in
the mcu
but as a sony production sony can cross
over any past villain it wants
regardless of their origin universe
which we know they're doing with jamie
foxx electro and alfred molina doc ock
with rumors then willem dafoe green
goblin and others might be involved and
molina just confirmed that his duck is
the one
last seen drowning in the river in sam
raimi's 2004 spider-man 2
saying quote in this universe no one
ever really dies
so if electro from the mark webb
universe and doc ock from the reigning
universe can suddenly
appear in the mcu sony could totally
extend that batshit logic to venom or
carnage
but narratively why would they cross
over
well let's ask doctor strange the mcu's
chief multiverse navigator confirmed to
be peter parker's mentor in no way home
now doctor strange was recently revealed
to have also been the source of the
commercials of wandavision
messages warning the scarlet witch to
consult the doctor
about her nexus being abilities wanda
now appears to be ignoring that
prescription
self-medicating with the darkhold as she
scours the multiverse for a reality with
her lost children in it
and ahead of wanda's confirmed return in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness the scarlet witch may have
inadvertently created another hex
causing some children to go missing as
we've seen in no way home set photos
and causing spidey villains from
alternate realities
to pop up in the mcu in no way home now
meanwhile back in the sony venom
universe i have speculated let there be
carnage will be an adaptation mix of
maximum carnage and absolute carnage the
latter of which
features carnage taking over a cult of
worshippers of the symbiote klyntar
deity
no and creating an army of drones and
with a title like let there be carnage
yeah carnage is probably gonna go
god mode in this movie which is pretty
scary considering he is a sadistic
serial killer
so if they play this out carnage in his
army could go on a total
killing spree a sort of mini genocide
carnage could win this movie which would
leave this venom universe in such a
wreck
a state of carnage some might say that
carnage could after this victory get
recruited
to join a team of worst of the worst
villains from across the multiverse
a sinister sixth lineup from the
spider-verse hall of infamy and this all
happened because the scarlet witch
opened the door
and the sinister six was able to rush
through it so maybe the reason
spider-man doesn't appear in venom and
carnage's universe yet
is that sony who remembers shifted their
release schedule around so that morbius
could come out after no way home now
but strictly kept let there be carnage
so that it had to come out before no way
home
sony could have a plan to use the mcu's
multiverse of madness to give
their villains a truly bonker cinematic
crossover
support this channel by checking out one
of our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos subscribe
to the rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you